siri services over 2 billion requests a
week from customers and there's so many
things that you can ask Siri but now an
iOS 10 series going to be able to do so
much more because we're opening up Siri
to developers
now you'll be able to ask Siri things
like send a wee chat to Nancy saying
I'll be five minutes late and Siri can
summon up the wee chat you I right
inside of the Siri environment now of
course Siri because it understands the
domains things like messaging allows you
to say things in so many different ways
I could have said we chat Nancy that all
be five minutes later I need to send a
message to Nancy via WeChat saying I'll
be five minutes late and I could do that
in all sorts of different languages but
because now in iOS 10 we have an intense
API it allows Siri to take on that part
of the work and lets the extension do
what it does best like messaging and so
now we support messaging with apps like
slack and whatsapp and of course we chat
can do things like ride booking in serie
with services like uber lyft and DD in
China foto search within apps like I am
shutterfly and Pinterest and you can
start a pause and stop your workouts in
apps like map my run runtastic and
RunKeeper and even do payments to send
money to friends with things like number
26 square cash and Ally pay in China and
do VoIP calling through apps like Cisco
spark vonage and skype and it works
great in the car as well because with
carplay you can now safely send your
messages as well as make VoIP calls all
inside the car play environment with
your favorite apps and that's a quick
update on Cirie
you